[Musik]
jetzt geschichte und der völlig fremden
person und konnte sich somit aus mexiko
ok und an der straße im standesamt
gegangen mein körper
[Musik]
si
die kalorien
[Musik]
hin und weg sie was claudia aus zürich
am jakobus paris so faszinierend wunder
hat definitiv auf amerika zu politisch
das religiöse finden
[Musik]
seither sind noch zwei mitglieder zu
europa unterwegs
[Musik]
und der ehemalige profi basketballer
schmeißt inzwischen ein großer teil von
hus
[Musik]
pizza du bei mir wie vor herrscht schaue
alles geschwister und ich bin mir was
sie zum abgleich anstrengung streng ich
beruflich ging klar mit ihrem ehemann
group aber der preis entscheidend das
hat auch claudia passt schon mit 18 ist
sie auch zirkus artistik usa gang sport
daraus profit entrée für stars wie dj
ötzi oder besten ist geformt und seine
musikvideos gesungen
[Musik]
labbadia war am einfachsten
verhältnissen
basketball hat mich eigentlich gerettet
wenn ich nicht sport getrieben hätte
wäre ich vermutlich noch dort meine
mutter hat mir beigebracht zu tun was
man tun möchte meine mutter war eine
kämpferin sie und mein vater standen
immer um fünf uhr in der früh auf um
nach paris zu fahren und dort läden zu
putzen
mein vater arbeitete als straßenreiniger
es war immer mein traum mit dem sport so
viel geld zu verdienen dass sie nicht
mehr arbeiten müssen und das habe ich
gemacht
der group und claudia sind beide sehr
jung für europa und amerika zum großen
traum verwirklichen
das sexy von amit genannt verbunden der
stand seit die videos der städte die
ihre karrieren aufbaut und dann hat ihn
keiner plant und durch gewissen wenn du
mit ihm wechseln sie du musst alles oft
alles aus aachen am efsf gebe es immer
noch einmal vorgemacht wie tanzen singen
der kuss ist nicht weg sie und spieler
freuen was auch immer mit ihrem
maximilian service tour und ich kann das
hat nicht gewusst was menschen wirklich
dicker was mir machen was macht denn
doch mal irgendwo beispiel in der frage
oder was ist dass er dafür sorge dass
die usa an das wasser immer traurig und
zumindest das repertoire aber das glück
nicht alle dass sie das nicht muss das
halt direkt auf das wird für die wird
immer alles gemacht das sind können das
eben alle sich oliver burget und frage
und ich glaube sich auch damit müsst ihr
auch die beschäftigen dortmund mehr viel
ein land schön das heißt muss jetzt
alles was dir alles sagen dann hat er
sein und wo man irgendwie schon so dass
schlicht billiger kaufen und dann gegen
ried wo frauen und ein baby care wo man
sachen anhänger scherte bringen
beide mannschaften den ball die
spielerfrauen events sogar um die akkus
gesehen und eigentlich wert verliere
warum heißt das gemacht für infos für
die zukunft was mir eine weile reichen
familie und ihren acht merck ist nur es
da sie will eben halt so im flower hat
werden sie wenn ich mir da bin
drei minuten später geschlossen
ich sage der maschine zwischen hast du
gemerkt dass so viele frauen um sich
geworfen habe ja das habe ich schon im
college gemerkt da kommen alle zu den
spielen und man ist schon ein bisschen
ein star als profi hat sich das dann
verziehen verzwanzigfacht
die leute sehen dich am fernsehen
sie wissen dass du viel geld verdienst
und ein gutes leben fürst dann wollen
sie natürlich daran teilhaben
ariana und alessia sich amerika geboren
und kleiner tweets nur versuchten die
großeltern
sie redet englischen ihren hintern
schweizer deutschlands ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben nun kinder und familie müssen
sicherstellen dass alle zufrieden sind
wir haben eine vorstellung wie wir es
machen wollen
aber vielleicht landen wir in einer
sackgasse
und natürlich gab es auch zweifel daran
ob das alles wirklich klappen wird
[Musik]
die laufserie
china kann
musik 500 kilometer trainiert florence
von niklas aber beide schaffen ihren
gemeinsamen projektes mit dem
schwäbischen wald es gemeinsam sei für
sich und mindestens acht und da sagt
nach schweden bis im schlafzimmer bord
fing am stück ja da zum 20 geburtstag
von mami buch und ja ich hatte schöne
kindheit machen
jetzt wird ihnen insgesamt mit der sach-
lebens- oder farbig strichen
überschuldet ist schlafzimmer in fast
immer eine gute jahr wird florence
zubler weg von der dinge bei costa
schweiz weg von der dichterin und
familie
jetzt ist so der punkt wodurch aussage
zuletzt summe letzt herbst und fordern
uaeine und das ist auch sehr bewusst
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja das gute ist du kannst
einfach drüber malen
du musst es nicht abschleifen nicht zu
viel farbe auf den pinsel perfekt
florence ich besten siebter da sie hat
das gut sozialnetz was gibt sie aber so
für ihren schwedische mal der große
verantwortlich für die nicklas wichtig
dass man ziemlich und 1300 thema mit
radsatz immer noch heuer wird vieles
anders wenn ich ihn richtig schweden
aufbricht
zunächst schauten jetzt langsam an die
zu bemerkte er sich gut und natürlich
immer beim am mikro und hofft mit der
neuen superstars ist navigate ist nahe
ist also nicht vorstellig werden sie den
umgang miteinander das verrät es schon
das thema natürliche neuer hätten
angststörung und katrin forschungsreise
das machte abschied von dem motto noch
viel schwieriger unbedingt ein problem
dass sich die leute bringen blieb den
beiden
[Musik]
die reform hat sie ich hoffe eines
täglich und zudem hätte ich das weg auch
nicht groß die frage nicht gestellt weil
das magazin dass er weg heißt schweiz
das strahle sichere auto widows probiert
das ist ganz klar gesehen dass einmal
gewusst meint kristin und wie lange der
schweiz htc und das ist alles
[Musik]
vor 48 stunden sind martina und dort
darüber stürzt in syrien flocke weg der
korona krise und der grenzschließung
sind viel früher wusste schwyz weg als
ursprünglich geplant kein moment früher
wie sich zeigt
am 1
machst du dir sorgen wegen den wie hoch
das einzige worüber ich mir sorgen mache
ist dass sich das virus in deine familie
bringen könnte aber ich habe kein
einziges im ton und fühle mich gut
[Musik]
der australischen westküste oft wachsen
wie sehr vor zwei jahren zu den martin
aufbruchs politisch hat er australien
und liefern
oh nein
noch eine stunde dann sind wir ein user
[Musik]
das ist diesmal vom juni damit könnte
man die verstrahlung drei stunden von
bayer
bisher fliegt
meine mutter wird sich extrem freuen
sie erwarten uns überhaupt nicht vor
allem jetzt mit dem corona virus wir
dachten er auch wir könnten nicht
fliegen
ich bin so froh dass wir jetzt hier sind
ja die haben keine ahnung
ich zittere ich bin so nervös
die zwei entnehmen zeit dass ich darüber
dass seine branche werde für die älteren
und schwester von kate überraschte
[Musik]
hätte ich das gewusst hätte ich
abgewaschen um mich gekämpft
vater zieht gerade seine uniform an und
macht sich bereit zur arbeit zu gehen
welche überraschung
die letzten 48 stunden waren so
aufregend das ist die beste überraschung
in meinem ganzen leben
[Musik]
ich danke dir ganz fest dass du so gut
auf meinen jungen aufgepasst hast
[Musik]
es happy end noch erlanger und ungewisse
reise
unter start vom gemeinsamen lebens
australien
[Musik]
da haben sie schützen und der heimat
bezeichnen aber hat mich das besser wie
das ist für den job für job und wenn
dies besser obwohl ich gerne der schweiz
763 unter ob die hand und meine
schwester session genauigkeit auch nicht
das machen wir wieder macht in der
schweiz wie das nicht funktioniere
[Musik]
mit begleitung claudia dalbert sie ist
also privat sich in dieser ehrlichkeit
krajnik was mich erwartet
[Musik]
sogar in metern jetzt gehen wir zum 3
und da ist jetzt gerade am trainieren
und hoffe türen und fenstern für wahr
halte und untersucht und ist dann ja
was machte professioneller
fußballspieler also dass ein rich geheiß
richtig jaha verein für einen spieler
hat auch ein athlet wieder gut also
macht vor allem für profisportler ja
alles nur profisportler oder ein kleines
mädel chefs also mehr die kirche unter
mir wo du mich angestellt sind wodurch
der vermittler und halte mich spezifisch
und mit einer hand an der heimat so viel
wie nicht an
[Musik]
also ist das villenviertel so das ist
der hintere teil von roswell viele
athleten darunter große
das nicht gerade parlamentsgebäude das
ist das private das rasch auf und
monument wird das doch
[Musik]
amerika alles größeres weiß man
eigentlich aber das basketballfeld auf
dem vorplatz mit jedem
[Musik]
der stolzen schlüssel oder die
grundsteuer a und h
[Musik]
das sind alles themen die mir hat man
mehr
[Musik]
die angst dass der priester sei er weiß
dass man das begehbare es war ne
schlagen kriegen wir alles schön
aussteller
das sind die maße wachsen um größte
gefühl so einen begehbaren kühlschrank
hat kleiderschrank für frauen aber das
begehbare also vorratsschrank gibt der
begehrten immer alles umzustellen und er
hat das ehepaar gehören und ich finde
dass er war mega cool
dann werden wir alles schön aurich damit
mir immer gesehen sollten hand und hat
damit ist congstar to land braucht aber
denn sie schnitten jetzt für steaks und
erlebt aber dann koche und erwäge
einfach lästige frauenhaus zu ihren
rechten zu leiden hat okay aus
eingestuft was auch befolgt
wir sind ein wunder schafft immer noch
für inhaber muss immer aufpassen und
haben jetzt nach befreundet sie wieder
durch ihre freundschaft ein star es
selbst nicht das natürlich passieren
aber ich besser professionell polte will
sicht ist ein schwieriger mit dem
schaffen mit dem zahlen
unterlasse finden wie es geht wie macht
man das die balance dreifach klar die
gesetze der usa zum beispiel jahre schon
meine spieler oder optional in moskau
mit einer aber regelmäßig wie man muss
immer danke und das ist mir wichtig dass
man eben wieder erschafft und ein teil
vom autor oder familie ist
[Musik]
also mit die karriere oder wenn die
jungs
[Musik]
und während audi aus es macht kümmert
sich der klub die heimkind als wandelnde
kletterbaum drückt man ja schließlich
ein zwei meter großer baum
[Musik]
checkt gut
wer sich die robert rückrunde und hat
danach mühsam wieder hat eben auch sie
sind hat dann kein job
ich hoffe jetzt ich und du du bist du
okay
damit sei ein vorvertrag absage vergeben
ok und da hinten geschaut diskussionen
nein findet sich jetzt mehr gleichzeitig
megastolz fertig ist das denkt dass er
das so packe ich ihnen immer ganz einmal
ganz anderes setting keine client oder
alles ist immer um ihn jetzt noch mehr
als früher hat er was immer ticket
kollege und jetzt an ihrem ticket für
irgendwelche game studies und so und
nimmer etwas probleme mit dem breit wenn
wir schon das geld bekommt ist ein
ganzes spiel war heimat grosse
diskussionen über den knopf zum lassen
also doch auf dauer der kuchen
meistens geschieht und die gruppe ist
ein bisschen zimmer hat die ganze schöne
woche und dann auch wieder
[Musik]
da sind des dorfes dass ich so sehen die
spieler hören dass ich daraus ein
golfspieler und golfspieler amex oper
bis hin zur hand dann hoch meisten stars
sucht will sind dann meistens im moment
ihre nennt sich das ist aber dahin haben
es als nakba tag wind sofort frischen
podkoren was ist das für ein
[Musik]
doch lily 50 und jetzt mache das nur und
erst seit kurzem mit mir hat ja es ist
richtig sie und jetzt ist man ist
gefördert zum zurücklehnen und mit natur
aber immer jedem bossi und einfach mit
einsamkeit und sich saubere spiele und
auf das freue mich unheimlich
noch ist es nicht so wie früher liegt
2020 es lieben auf der ganzen welt auf
den kopf gestellt und autos von florence
und niklas
vector koroma krise sind die regelmäßige
psyche vorläufig nur möglich
die ist natürlich jetzt gerade auf einem
herd pro woche
und ja immer man du willst mir doch
nicht wenn das ist natürlich wieder
starten und doch einen moment relativ
schwierig für die spd später hat ja ja
das klappt und ich momentan nicht direkt
ins studio in berlin
ganze flog das wie ganze reihe 20 30 in
der die musiker frank also möglich
[Musik]
hey hallo wie geht's dir studiert jetzt
gut und hier hast du stress
ja wir haben mit krone jobs angefangen
demontieren plexiglas und rezeptionen
und kassen war etwas mit dem haus heute
heute war niemand dort wie geht's dir im
quarantäne land immer noch das gleiche
ich lass dich jetzt deinen corona jobs
ja wir haben immer noch drei orte für
uns bist du okay
ja klar
[Musik]
fox
fernbeziehung führen als ehepaar nicht
per se schwierig aber wenn das virus
noch grenze dicht macht grünem englisch
hilfe wenn sich florence und der
nikolaus wieder im tor stehen
wer beides steht jetzt ganz viel plant
sowie 1000 den sparen sparen hens
hunderttausend franken auf dem konto
findet ihr wenn das jetzt nutzen wir
wissen nicht wann wir sie nicht als sie
zwei jahre schon mal wenn die natur und
das machen wir mit leidenschaft erleben
als außer vielleicht auch der hauptstadt
im büro tätig
[Musik]
im jetzt leben mache oftmals scheint das
tönt nach manila die topnews im westen
vor australien
im elternhaus von payment martina und
ihren mann nach der überstürzten abreise
aus der schweiz zwei wochen die garanten
einer verbringen
so strahlend australische sumo wirkt
martina fg die schweiz aber das leid von
rapper ihre freunde unter abschied von
der ältere und der zwillingsschwester
sitzt auch noch
[Musik]
ich freue mich für seine familie
vermisst aber es ist okay verließ man
bewerte dies dass ich mein das pult und
wahrscheinlich noch regen und sonne
tanken
und vielleicht ist ja kurz geht diese
möglichkeit uns lebt fahrer zum
familientag nis wenn sie nicht
geschaffen sind
zumal es kloaken sie ihre gedanken
machen was man genau wenn wir alles wenn
der organisieren und start also
vielleicht ist ja nicht schlecht aber es
ist nicht so wie man es ist vorgestellt
[Musik]
bis wo sich vor allem die cale copf
freute
wie fühlst du dich so cool so viel
größer als ich es in erinnerung hatte
[Musik]
vor ihm selber frühjahre umbaut und
jetzt wieder zurückkauft mit erklärt
wenn wir beide in der nächsten minute
oder der ganze kontinent reisen
[Musik]
die welt unterwegs
das geld muss gott und martina eine
arbeitsbewilligung über hunt
[Musik]
noch zwei jahre der schweiz jetzt also
zu australiens pro jahr oder für immer
ok und martina lenz offen
[Musik]
carigiet hip hop für erfolg
mir gefällt's in quarantäne
[Musik]
eine schlimme ist dass sie ist weder
französin noch muslime das war
vielleicht ein problem sagen sonst seien
eigentlich wollte die familie jemanden
für mich auswählen
deine mama hatte schon jemanden im kopf
nicht unbedingt eine mutter halt sie
wollen einen immer beschützen
jetzt rächt den jüngsten beschluss
akzeptierte sie meine entscheidung
und jetzt ist es gut
also sagen wir besser
[Musik]
ja
also ich süchtig und familie diawara
machten ausflug ist grüne
[Gelächter]
beutler amerikanischen ganzer kraft spd
schon jetzt in panik
sie sehen könnten übrigen der besorgung
machen das ist man immer aufpassen weil
jugendhaus hat sich definitiv kein tritt
der korpus unterdessen präsent
[Musik]
ok unterschied gibt es viel wie deine
beide herkunft religion und auch
körpergröße gemeinsamkeiten aber genauso
nie geschafft für das was man macht die
beiden sind und der glaube an die
gemeinsame zukunft
die zukunft der usa erstmals in der liga
und dem spielmannzug schweiz nicht genau
der coup wie die schweiz
was genau wie immer größer und mich
fragt in der schweiz ist das brot und
wasser
du bekommst den schweizer pass wir
arbeiten kannst du dir vorstellen die
usa zu verlassen um in der schweiz zu
leben
warum nicht ich bin ja europa vielleicht
könnte ich in sachen basketball etwas
neues in die schweiz bringen
ich könnte den schweizern die
italienische die französische oder auch
die amerikanische spielweise beibringen
ich habe ja überall gespielt das wäre
cool warum nicht wenn du dich wünschen
auch so für zu erkrankten familie
dass man endlich mal fix betriebe
zündeten
mein wunsch war es in der nba zu spielen
kinder und eine frau zu haben
nun wünsche ich mir alles was ich
gelernt habe weitergeben zu können
jetzt könnte ich zurückgeben was ich
bekommen habe
verschiedene länder ist die heimatliebe
sich geführt und weg
[Musik]
die kolonie